i'm stuart varney i'm martha mccallum
i'm jason chaffetz and this is the fox
news rundown
friday august 20th 2021 i'm jessica
rosenthal as the work continues to get
desperate u.s citizens and afghans out
of afghanistan others are looking ahead
for those who will remain there what
will life be like under the taliban now
i don't have a lot of faith right now
that
anything will be different between the
taliban of 2021 in the taliban of 2001.
i'm lisa brady how much political
fallout could the president face over
the fall of afghanistan you know does
this mean it's the end of the biden
presidency no and every president goes
through some bad times but these are
really bad times and
afghanistan is is a real failure for
this administration we speak with fox
news sunday host chris wallace
and i'm geraldo rivera i've got the
final word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
the state department and pentagon say
the u.s military is working to evacuate
u.s citizens and legal residents who
were in afghanistan as the taliban took
over but there are reports indicating
that it's difficult to get to the
airport in kabul that the taliban
members are stopping people from getting
in pentagon spokesman john kirby we are
in communication obviously with
the local taliban commander about
making sure
um that uh those at-risk afghans uh
special immigrant visa applicants uh and
and you know additional uh afghan
citizens that we want to to move through
are able to move through and um
and it really it comes down a lot to the
credentialing and and making sure that
they can prove and we can prove that uh
that these are appropriate people to
move through and while officials say
they are also working to get vulnerable
afghans out many others desperately want
to leave others who maybe did not work
with the u.s but people like professor
najibulla yusefi in kabul who believes
he's a taliban target all the people
feel alone
and feel fear and especially women and
girls yusefi teaches girls at the mawwat
academy which was bombed three years ago
i asked him how he feels as america
leaves after 20 years we are shocked
we are surprised and we are shocked and
because
our government
unfortunately our government
doesn't have enough motivation
to fight with taliban soldiers he said
he believes there will be a civil war
and that while his government may not
have the motivation to fight the taliban
the people do he said they just need
leadership if it's possible the u.s army
come back and save the people yusefi
says the us will have a moral problem on
our hands if we watch the taliban
slaughter afghan civilians and fail to
return to stop them saying there isn't
much hope among the people right now so
i was in mazatia reef when it fell holly
mckay is a freelance war correspondent
and the author of only cry for the
living and i'd been there a few days
with my photographer and we were just
doing interviews and
kind of trying to capture the front
lines
and everyone that i'd spoken to really
assured me that mazar was completely was
not going to fall it was a very staunch
anti-taliban stronghold and had been
that way for 20 years
and everyone just was very confident
that there was no way and it was going
if it was going to fall that wouldn't
happen for several weeks
so i didn't really feel when i was there
initially that there was anything to be
concerned about people were in the
street the markets were full
and we just had an amazing time the the
energy and the vitality was just
incredible and then as the hours started
to go by you really felt this sense of
people were suddenly disappearing from
streets and stores were closing early
and that second darkness hit you there
wouldn't be a soul and so i started to
feel a little unnerved and then on the
day that it happened
it was just a bizarre ghost town and i
remember i was sick and i wasn't i
wasn't really feeling well and we went
out and we wanted to go closer to the
front line and we got in a cab and we
drove a little bit along an abandoned
road heading out of the city and then a
cab driver just looked at us and he said
we need to stop i'm scared we need to
turn around and my photographer and i
sort of looked at each other because we
were both
sort of under the impression that that
things were really in control
and we went out early that evening to
get some kebabs and there was just
nobody in the street
and there was no noise and that was the
eerie part it wasn't
it wasn't that there was a lot of noise
it was the real lack of noise in the
city and
we just
said do you feel something's wrong and
we agreed and we sort of hired back to
our guest house and as we hurried back
motorcycles came in and that was the
taliban
we talked to a teacher in kabul and he
said the taliban members are saying all
the right things you know like that
girls can still go to school and the
media can keep operating etc but he said
don't believe them you know watch their
actions not their words
um are you
seeing or hearing um about their actions
i mean we've heard reports that taliban
members are
beating people taking their documents
as they try and get to the airport i
don't have a lot of faith right now
that
anything will be different between the
taliban of 2021 and the taliban of 2001
and again that really will require them
to to show up instead of speaking it but
there is a very interesting pr spin
going on especially from the top
leadership but on the ground uh the
leadership can only control so much and
so you do have a lot of very rogue
elements especially in a lot of
provinces and my fear is that once the
u.s withdrawal is complete and the
foreigners all leave
it really will be the afghans that are
left to that kind of slaughter and they
know that and they're terrified yeah i
was going to ask you what what are the
afghan people telling you about their
fears of the future do they have
any hope or is it mostly just fear
they're terrified they i'm yet to really
meet anybody
that's not in the taliban that supports
the taliban people are terrified people
uh have enjoyed a certain sense of
freedom over the past 20 years
especially in urban areas like kabul
where women can have a lot more choice
and when how they choose to leave the
house in being able to go places on
their own to be educated to think that
they would have to give all that up
whether they're a journalist or an
artist they're just desperate to to
escape they're trying to write letters
to appeal to the us government and even
resorting to
being smuggled into other countries just
because they they know the fate that
awaits them and they're just so
desperate to get out it's really
heartbreaking because i feel
uh very gutted that i can't do more for
them other than help support them with a
letter or refer them to an organization
that's really set up to do that earlier
this week president biden defended his
handling of the withdrawal insisting he
had to either continue to withdraw fully
as the trump administration had
committed to or send more troops in
which would risk renewed taliban attacks
president biden said we would stay
beyond august 31st if we need to in
order to evacuate everyone including
afghans and their families hugo lorenz
was the u.s ambassador in kabul in 2016
and 17 and previously held an ambassador
ranked position in 2012 in afghanistan
as well if you were going to ask me that
it was all going to end
um on this past sunday on august
the 15th no i but i i wouldn't have
given it too much more time i mean my
sense is
that the decision to so rapidly so
rapidly and precipitously remove us and
by by extension nato forces from
afghanistan
so uh in such a quick manner
um would leave the afghan security
forces really up in the air and the end
result would be both
a collapse in the morale of the force
as well as their military capability so
i expected that by sort of the latter
part of this year if you're looking at
october and november in my mind i think
it would be very clear
that the situation for
our friends in in afghanistan our allies
in the government kabul would be uh they
would be in a very bad way
no surprises uh but obviously it
happened much quicker than i expected
so
i guess my the the question then is um
should we have stayed should we have
stayed indefinitely
remember we were not
fighting the war like 10 years ago we
didn't have a hundred thousand men we
weren't spending 130 billion dollars on
the war
we were we were having casualties that
were a fraction of u.s training
accidents every year in the us army
we in the from 2015 to 2020 we never
lost more than 22 men killed in action
again every life is precious but
um it's important to have respect
and in the treasure perspective i'm
saying we were spending two and a half
percent of defense spending so we were
in a position to sustain it
we were residual force but what we
brought to the table were advisors
that were embedded in afghan units that
will help them be very effective
okay they made sure that the soldiers
were getting paid they were getting food
that they were getting munitions and the
afghans are tough fighters if they get
food and and they get their pay they're
gonna fight
obviously that system started breaking
down once we removed all all of our
forces and we had some special forces
that were used effectively but at the
margin and then finally the most
important thing jessica was the air
piece we had a very small air force in
afghanistan maybe 90 100 aircraft but we
had a basing network all over the
country and we have a very effective air
force if the taliban concentrated a
hundred guys
in 15 minutes you're going to have an
aircraft with precision or
ordinance
dropping stuff on them so wait but are
you saying that we but are you saying
that we should have stayed
with the small force that we had that
that was working correct if you would
have told me i'm an american citizen and
i'm a taxpayer you told me should we
keep a hundred thousand troops in
afghanistan fifty thousand troops in
afghanistan should we spend a hundred
billion dollars is it worth it i would
agree with presidents trump and biden
but that was not the situation the
situation is we had a small residual
force of some advisors small number of
special forces and a very small maybe
one and a half percent two percent of
the us air force was deployed in
afghanistan we could have kept it until
such time
till both sides
realized that there was no military
victory to be had
and they would come to it to the table
um and negotiate an afghan agreement
uh which would have been a political
settlement probably some type of power
sharing
i mean i'm not going to negotiate for
the afghans but i think that would have
been the result and based on that the us
and its allies could have could have
withdrawn
ambassador tell me um your thoughts on
the future here i i spoke to a teacher
in kabul this week he is terrified he
taught women and girls he thinks he's a
target
and he wants to get out um i think he's
probably pretty low on the totem pole
since we can't even seem to get our own
folks out um
but
he's afraid of the future uh with with
the taliban in charge and he said you
know they're saying all the right things
right like
um girls can still go to school and
we're going to have an inclusive
government etc but he said you know he
doesn't believe them and i'm just
wondering based on your experience there
and based on the fears of the the people
who are
not in support of the taliban what does
the future hold for this country
um i would be very worried i mean i'm
getting i i have a lot of afghan friends
and i'm hearing pretty credible reports
that they're you know barging into
people's houses taking their property
um they are
looking for
uh senior military officers senior
intelligence officers um uh you know
there are lots of reports particularly
outside of kabul of executions of
you know of uh
bad treatment of women
schools are closed outside of kabul so
again i think you have to be very very
worried but your question is a good one
jessica i mean the us and
and the international community has to
send a very clear message to the taliban
that they won't get a penny
of u.s uh and international economic
assistance unless they respect the
rights of their people
uh and particularly women
um and and it starts also with
cooperating with the us in being able to
get all american citizens
out of uh afghanistan which is something
as you know we're working on right now
um and also to get uh the thousands of
afghans who worked in our embassy who
worked with our military and risked
their lives um in this fight and we owe
it to them to bring them back and not
leave anyone behind so i think that
would be our first priority would let's
get our people home um and the next one
the next one is that the world will not
recognize the taliban unless they
respect the rights of their own people
ambassador lorenz thank you so much for
your time thank you jessica
[Music]
this is geraldo rivera with your fox
news commentary coming up
not much brings congress together these
days but what's happening in afghanistan
has crossed the aisle we deserve answers
we intend to get answers pennsylvania
congresswoman sue wilde is one of the
democrats supporting calls for
congressional hearings she says it was
past time to withdraw but not like this
the manner in which this was executed
was clearly not a success story and to
say anything other than that
is a disservice to the service men and
women the white house already is
juggling a number of other challenges
including the ongoing fight with covet
could afghanistan derail the president's
entire agenda i doubt it but you know
defeat plays on itself and a perception
of failure and weakness plays on itself
chris wallace is the host of fox news
sunday there's no question that joe
biden and his administration and his
agenda is weaker today than it was a
week ago today having said that
do i think that house democrats are
going to vote against the infrastructure
bill because the president mishandled
afghanistan probably not but he's in a
weaker position no question about it
i mean there have been some supportive
statements from fellow democrats you
know house speaker nancy pelosi comes to
mind
there hasn't really been a rush to the
president's defense on this though is
that a sign that they're worried about
the wider and longer term potential
political implications of this
yeah i don't think it's that so much i
listen i think that if you were to take
a poll of all the statements verbal and
written from democratic members of
congress the vast majority have been
critical and i think the reason is
because there's really no other response
yes i did see that nancy pelosi was
talking about how strong the president
was i i don't
i don't think anybody uh other than die
hard democrats are going to buy that
look you've got in the senate but most
of these committees will all the
committees are run by democrats they
have the majority of a thai vote plus
the vice president and you've had people
like
intelligence committee chair mark warner
democrat of virginia and bob menendez
democrat of new jersey who's the head of
the house foreign foreign relations
committee and they're all saying we're
going to have hearings on this look
this was a failure it was a screw-up the
policy
was very questionable and the execution
was unquestionably bad and there's just
no way you can get around it and you can
be a loyal democrat but you can't put
lipstick on this pig
what about the potential for kind of a
compounding effect i mean republicans
certainly are saying look this is just
another example of the crises that this
administration creates which i'm sure
the white house would dispute that you
know perspective
but in the latest fox news poll that was
taken earlier this month
um some other issues
you know had been rising sort of to the
top of things that
people said they were concerned about
either extremely or very
concerned about you know the coronavirus
and health care still up there but also
things like violent crime
and inflation and immigration oh look
the president
had a a really good ride for about four
or five months and
um i know some of the listeners are
going to say it's because he had an easy
press things seem to be going pretty
well and particularly covet seem to be
going very well
but with the rise of the delta variant
and the huge spike and we're now seeing
over 100 000 new cases a day and the
continuing crisis of the border and
that's what you have to call it when
you've got 100 000 people coming across
the border every month and inflation
going up and now a complete failure
after 20-year war in you know i i don't
i think according to the polls most
people were
supported the idea of getting out of
afghanistan i don't think that was a
politically unpopular position
and and lord knows it's what donald
trump said in motion with the peace deal
he made with the taliban back in 2020
it's the execution of it and the fact
that we seem to have been so flat-footed
and we seem to have and we still have 15
000 americans there and 65 000 afghans
who helped us and that we have promised
to get out of the country still stuck
there so you know does this mean it's
the end of the biden presidency no and
every president goes through some bad
times but these are really bad times and
afghanistan is is a real failure for
this administration it's really been a
mess on every level policy intelligence
pr optics politics it's been a mess
the delta search of kovid doesn't seem
to be nearly over yet is is there
something more the administration
should be doing on that besides things
like you know requiring nursing home
staffers to get vaccines
well
yes and no i mean you know i there's
obviously this has become hugely
politicized the fact that you now have
and i i say this in quote civil wars
going on in some of these states between
the governors in florida and texas for
instance who have
bans on masks in schools mass mandates
and schools and school districts in
florida you just had miami-dade the
largest school district in the state and
i think one of the top three or four in
the country
basically
just ignore the governor rather and say
no we're going to have imposed a math
mandate
you know and to a certain degree
the
the the president certainly has talked
enough as much as he could about
vaccines and masks and you know when you
have a hundred million americans or just
about who refuse or eligible for
vaccines and refusing to get it i'm not
sure what more the president can do
i'm wondering too whether the new
booster shot plan might actually end up
being a deterrent for people who are
already hesitant to get the first shot
if they now know that they may end up
needing three shots
well if it is if they if they view it as
a deterrent
they're foolish i mean first of all my
own view is
i got the shot the minute that i was
that i was able to get it as an older
person i was able to get
you know in february but you know i i
remember i was at my home and about an
hour away from the hospital that called
up and said uh you're eligible for a
shot today would you like that i got in
the car and i went
and let me tell you the day that i'm
eligible for a booster shot i'm going to
go get it so
you know it's sort of like saying if
you're going to be wildly reckless and
careless and what 97 or 8 percent of the
people who are in hospitals are
unvaccinated yes you can get at delta
even with the vaccination but you're
very much less likely to end up in the
hospital or dead you know if if if
that's not enough and if they're now
saying to you well there's some waning
effectiveness from this and you need to
get a booster and if you do your your
antibodies will be boosted by 10 times
again you know i just listen to science
i listen to facts and you know i don't
understand why people aren't getting it
and i certainly don't understand why a
booster would make you less likely to
get it
there's some pushback from the world
health organization one official likens
it to
giving an extra life jacket to someone
who's already got one while other people
are drowning
are we losing sight of the worldwide
picture of this pandemic
yes there's no question about it i mean
you know
as a factual matter
you could argue that if you've got
millions more now the us and president
biden have done more than any other
country in the world we're committed i
think to giving 600 doses out to other
countries in the world but when you
consider the population of the world 600
million doses is not much more than any
other country's given but it's not much
and you certainly could have made the
argument that that
dose that you know is going to be given
out as a booster could go better to
somebody who's completely unprotected
it's an interesting thing i i think
there's a line here in terms of
america first you know and i know that's
the the trump line but i think it's
pretty hard for
an american president or american
official to say yes you know there are
other people who need it more but if
there's an american citizen and your
protection is going to wane
you know that we we should give that to
somebody else and engage for you i mean
in the end
i
can understand where
the american leader would say we're
going to take care of our fellow
americans first before we take care of
other people and you know in an
interesting way i think there's a
comparison to afghanistan here i
remember when it was announced that
biden was going to pull all troops out i
talked to a top white house official a
woman and i said what about the afghan
women who are going to suffer if the
taliban takes over this is back in april
and she said look that may well happen
but in the end that's not in america's
national security interest we care
terribly about those women but we can't
send american men and women to fight and
potentially to die to protect afghan men
and women
yeah i guess it always comes back at
least partly to
how could it end up affecting us if we
do something or don't do it and like
with the booster shots i guess who's
argument is
well look if too many people remain
unvaccinated in other parts of the world
it allows
more transmission and allows the
potential for more
variants to develop
all of that is absolutely true on the
other hand the flip side of that
argument is
you know we're not going to solve the
world's problem with vaccines even if we
took 100 million or 200 million or 300
million doses we're talking about
billions of doses for to solve the
world's population so it's got to be a
worldwide response and you know in the
end we have to look to ourselves for to
protecting ourselves first it's a it's a
legitimate and very difficult and
painful policy argument but clearly
that's the decision the president has
made
one other quick question just about the
mood of the united states
because we saw that consumer confidence
plunge in the latest reading do you get
a sense people are
just discouraged especially watching the
coveted numbers rise so dramatically
again
absolutely look as i said earlier there
are a number of problems on and growing
problems on joe biden's plate right now
and afghanistan is one but rise in
covert numbers inflation the continuing
crisis at the border with
tens of thousands of people coming
across there are a lot of reasons that
americans aren't feeling as good about
the state of the country uh whether
we're on the right track and whether
this president
is is the guy keep us in the rhetoric it
happens to every president some are able
to get out of it some aren't and this is
joe biden's turn in the barrel
we'll see how he does
who do you have on the show this weekend
well we're going to have a top white
house official about afghanistan we're
also going to be talking to republican
senator ben sasse who's a member of the
senate intelligence committee we want to
find out what exactly was the
intelligence about a quick taliban
takeover and what do we do now i mean
yes part of it is looking back but i
think the most important thing and i
really want to focus on this with the
white house official is what do we do
now what do we do now in terms of
getting those 15 000 americans to the
airport 65 000
afghans who risked their lives to
protect us and what do we do in terms of
dealing with the taliban going forward
and most importantly what do we do in
terms of protecting the us homeland from
terror groups that may regenerate inside
afghanistan
chris wallace host of fox news sunday
thanks so much for your time
my pleasure lisa's good talking to you
[Music]
i'm guy benson join me weekdays at 3 pm
eastern as we break down the biggest
stories of the day with some of the
biggest newsmakers and guests listen
live on the fox news app or get the free
podcast at guybensonshow.com
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
locals in belfast harbor maine are
working to unravel a whodunit but this
isn't a murder mystery they're trying to
figure out how a 25 foot tall inflatable
yellow duck got into the harbor over the
weekend and just who put it there
as if the sight of a bright yellow
overgrown tub toy wouldn't be enough to
bring a smile to one's face the duck is
emblazoned with the word joy for good
measure
the bangor daily news reports that
harbor master catherine given says that
the floating waterfowl doesn't pose a
navigational hazard so they're not in a
hurry to shoo it away it's anchored in a
shallow part of the harbor the duck has
even been making an appearance on social
media with people posting photos of it
given says everyone loves it and a lot
of people seem to want to keep joy
around
tanya j powers fox news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
geraldo rivera
what's on your mind hi everybody this is
geraldo rivera reporting and like
millions of you i have afghanistan on my
mind
after 20 years we are cutting and
running from the chaotic south asian
country that we invaded two decades ago
after they provided safe haven to
al-qaeda the international terrorists
who murdered 3 000 of our friends and
neighbors on september 11 2001.
president trump wanted out obviously so
did joe biden after 2 500 dead gis and a
trillion dollars spent trump says he
would have left in a much more muscular
posture he says he would have bombed the
hell out of the taliban and the
equipment that we left behind if they
did anything to threaten americans or
our allies on the way out
maybe a trump withdrawal would have had
more dignity and strength we'll never
know
we do know that under president biden
our retreat has been a mess
despite taliban assurances that they
would facilitate the evacuation there
have been widespread incidents
of taliban forces interfering with our
people reportedly making their way to
the kabul airport the result is an
evacuation that is sputtering and
inefficient we have the planes but some
are leaving that dreadful airport half
empty because not enough passengers have
made their way through the taliban
checkpoints ringing the airport
as we learned in the decades following
vietnam defeat is a bitter pill to
swallow vietnam fell to the communists
way back in 1975
46 years ago
but the wound still festers the taliban
claims they are different than they once
were they say women and girls for
example will not be repressed under
their new government they say human
rights groups will be able to function
freely
having spent many months over 11
assignments there over as many years i
have deep doubts about that i am also
hurt by the gross dysfunction of our
withdrawal as i said defeat is always
hard to swallow but my god we could have
gotten out with dignity that honored the
memory of the tens of thousands who
served there so honorably in that rotten
place i'm geraldo rivera reporting fox
news
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
hey it's brett larsen inviting you to
download and listen to the new daily fox
on tech podcast there's part of a
colorful late 90s imac on mars it's an
idea that seems a lot like kickstarter
called build it subscribe and listen now
by going to foxnewspodcast.com or
wherever you get your podcasts